[Music]
classic films like jaws Lawrence of
Arabia
Gone with the Wind well it's like a
watch like do frankly my dear I don't
give a damn
[Applause]
and the original Star Wars
all have one thing in common
unforgettable scores
the music specifically written by
composers to enhance the film's dramatic
and emotional impact a great score can
move the story and the audience
[Music]
now there's a new documentary that
explores the creative process behind
this often overlooked aspect of
moviemaking it's titled simply enough
score the Trump's that were uniquely
recorded for Mad Max just playing one
if I make a track it has to give me
goosebumps myself I don't say that to be
arrogant but if it doesn't hit me in the
stomach as being a great piece of music
I cannot expect the audience anybody out
there to have a feeling that it hits a
stomach
I have goosebumps yeah no match Raiders
the film's writer and director he is
joined by Bear McCreary the composer for
says television hits his battlestar
galactica lactic ax and the walking dead
plus the recent film 10 Cloverfield Lane
gems good morning to you both good
morning I mean I do have the chills but
but baby just watch more clips yeah I
can do that in your mind what's the
difference between a good film score in
a bad film I think everything that we
just saw is a perfect example of a great
film score I think a good film score
creates a piece of our culture that we
all share it's a piece of music that we
all recognizes as having value and and
you know as far as a bad film score I
think it's just anything that fails to
connect with the audience the role of a
film score is to make real those
emotions that we want to feel anymore
like running up those stairs ideally to
elevate all of that as well
right how important is it to the success
of a film the film score boy I mean a
great film score it can make I don't
know if it can save a movie completely
but it can definitely make a very good
story it can make it great it make it
unforgettable Jurassic Park is such a
great example of that where there's just
such a unforgettable theme that just
gets stuck in your head and you love it
for the whole film it's it's so powerful
it works well in the scenes and and and
it can live outside of the film even for
years and years afterwards given all
that a score adds to a film how
competitive is the film scoring business
it's a really interesting question
because it in one way is very
competitive there's a certain number of
films made and a certain number of
composers that sort of are able to feed
that ecosystem but we also live in an
era where there's so much content that
needs music alright streaming shows web
series Indies features there's so much
music that needs to be made when young
composers ask me like how do I get in I
almost say well how do you not get in so
much work that needs to be done
you were saying he's one you wanted to
do this since you were five years old I
did when I was a kid I saw Back to the
Future when I was five and I made my mom
take me a second time and I had a little
fisher-price tape recorder and I held it
up to the screen I was like
bum-bum-bum I was like what is this I
reading it I was I was totally pirating
the score and then I found out you could
buy this thing called the soundtrack
yeah you could listen to the music but I
think from there I was doomed to to just
this is my life direction you know
what's the process like for you well the
process is really interesting because
filmmakers will bring me projects in
various stages of development sometimes
it's a script other times it's the
finished movie and then we talk about
what you want the audience to feel my
mentor Elmer Bernstein said that
ultimately that's the only question you
ever need to ask a filmmaker you don't
need to ask
do you like strings do you like oboes
you just say what do you want the
audience to feel right answering that
question is our our only job because
once you know that you want the audience
to feel terror or suspense or confusion
or bittersweet tragedy all of these
things you translate into something that
you tell your musicians ok the filmmaker
wants this so we're going to do this man
this must be an incredibly difficult
decision for the director because I
imagine some directors aren't actually
even quite sure what they want sometimes
yeah I mean it's there they're not a lot
of times directors aren't that
articulate when it comes to music and
the way to explain it and you have to
really get into you know some composers
joked you have to be like a therapist
with a director you know that's not a
joke man they're not joking you have to
but you have to have this emotional
language find this common ground and be
able to kind of explore the edges of
that in you know films especially big
ones like Lord of the Rings and The
Hobbit and a lot of the different themes
that go on for sometimes a series of
films you have to be on the same page
the movies change through the production
process do you wait till they're done to
begin scoring I like to I I was on a
film called 10 Cloverfield Lane produced
by JJ Abrams I was hired on almost two
years before the movie came out and I
thought a lot about what's it going to
sound like what are the different themes
gonna be but it ultimately when I saw
this movie I took a look at John Goodman
and his imposing presence and it's like
now I'm hearing ideas now the score
seems so inevitable I always say that a
film
tells you Phil tells you what it means
yeah but it has to exist in order to
tell you but sometimes what you think it
needs in the director think it needs
probably you aren't always the same
maybe a little different but that's part
of the job is getting on the same page
with with the filmmaker and it's their
job to be able to articulate something
and it's my job to be able to interpret
what they're saying and a lot of the
times it's you understand the meaning
behind what they are telling you okay
Bear McCreary thank you so much much
Reiter good luck with the film
Thanks somewhere is available in select
theaters and is available for pre-order
on iTunes will be a score